now back to Europe this time to Rome
we're on the set of his current
production the winner of an Oscar for
his moving performance in separate
tables will introduce the next category
ladies and gentlemen mr. David Niven
it's my privilege to announce the next
carry the awards for the best
achievements in cinematography now the
art directors and the set decorators put
the beauty on the sets the directors
place the actors in the middle of all
this beauty and didn't varying degrees
help them to put life and drama into the
words of the writers but whose Duty is
it to put all this drama and beauty on
film the cinematographers these masters
of lighting used some of the strangest
words in Hollywood for their equipment
the start they have lights called Broads
and others called inky's juniors peanuts
and headaches if they have too much
light they blotted out with gobos and
cutters and they even bend the Rays of
the Sun to their will with reflectors
and scribs too little of their great
artistry is known outside the studios
but when the efforts of all the rest of
us do look magnificent on the screen it
is because the cinematographers made
things so thank you very much David and
to make the presentation here as a young
lady who always looked magnificent on
the screen as he also looked magnificent
off I know as we work together in From
Here to Eternity and that's when she won
her Oscar Miss Donna Reed
thank you Frank you know it's been a
long way from eternity to here hasn't it
well let's not remind them Donna you
look just as lovely tonight as you did
then you haven't changed
you're sweet you think I've changed yes
you're sweet the ghost of us with great
pleasure and sincere admiration
I read the nominees for best achievement
in cinematography the black and white
picture Burnett Guffey for Birdman of
Alcatraz genre bland on Reaper Sam and
Walter what it's for the longest day
Russell Harlan for tequila Mockingbird
Ted nakorn for two for the seesaw
Ernest Tyler for whatever happened to
Baby Jane may I have the envelope please
the winners are jean-bob well on Reaper
Sarah and Walter wallets for longest day
excepting for Jean bagua our represent
and Walter whatit's is mr. Fred Metzler
three or can you I'm honored to accept
the awards for the three cameramen of
the longest day who could not be here
tonight I'm sure they will feel grateful
to all who made this possible thank you
the nominees for best achievement in
cinematography of a color picture are
Harry Stradling senior for gypsy Russell
Harlan for Hatari Fred alien for
Lawrence of Arabia Robert L Surtees for
mutiny on the bounty
Paul Steve Vogel for the wonderful world
of the Brothers Grimm and the winner the
winner is Fred a young for Lawrence of
Arabia
accepting on behalf of Fred a young miss
Carol Lynley
on behalf of mr. Jung and Columbia I
want to thank you very much for this
it's very richly deserved
he doesn't look like mr. young and I'm
glad